what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we are gonna watch knock
at the cabin today and who's we I'm
joined by my great friend all the way in
the east coast his name is Michael you
might know him better as Omni media Omni
please say hi to the reject Nation hi
guys here he is to check out this M
Night movie that may or may not hit yeah
the only M Night movie I have not seen
is old and this one of course is there
any other ones that are missing from
your plate that maybe you can react to
one day on your channel I've never
actually seen the happening for myself
but I've seen enough of it that I feel
like I have I know the feeling aside
from that I think I've seen every other
M9 movie Michael does reactions on his
channel in case you guys know please
give him a follow he's amazing at what
he does I love him there's a reason he
keeps coming back here so ladies and
gentlemen with that in mind please go
ahead knock at that like button see how
I did that it ties in with the title of
the movie also subscribe and click that
notification Bell to get notified when
we got another reaction up here on the
channel and also full-length Reaction
watch along is where you sing it with
your own copy of knock at the cabin
available for super sexy Rejects at our
patreon page we'll recover exclusively
several shows with reaction highlights
and watch alongs included sure Michael
has a similar thing he offers at his
patreon but I'm telling you to come to
mine go to his he needs it oh yeah way
more helping out this tiny tiny Channel
by being here today
all right Michael you ready ready all
right let's do it
[Music]
it's interesting I don't feel like I've
seen like the old school Universal
intro in a long time it's true I might
have done it for Invisible Man honestly
I don't remember
are these drawings on a
like test paper for students
it looks like it was like a
like a nurse's report
[Music]
well that's yes it is that's a menu
huh that's a napkin what does it mean
[Music]
foreign they needed to find some blank
paper
dude after The Happening he's got to
recycle more it's true
it's a well-trained grasshopper I've
never seen one just not immediately jump
away
I'm just gonna learn about you for a
little while
is that okay
okay at least she's getting their
consent Caroline my friend at school
she's really nice but she farts in class
sometimes and pretends like she didn't
please don't do that what a [__]
damn the sound design in this movie is
hitting the weight in these footsteps
you can hear it feel it and that's from
around here but I was hoping to make
some new friends can I talk to you for a
little bit I don't talk to strangers
oh I'm here to be your friend
so hopefully we won't be strangers for
too long
yikes uh everyone calls me one oh it's
nice to meet you one my name is Leonard
he is tatted up you call your dad by his
first name it said they know who I'm
talking to they're study Eric and Daddy
I see all the other kids at school only
have one dad
all the Disney Channel shows only have
one tattoo oh calling out you're called
out Disney fix it
what's wrong nothing at all
Two Dads is an abomination
now he's the one trying to get out of
this conversation
[Laughter]
happy almost birthday
for you so consider it an early birthday
present
what is it we'll take turns pulling
pedals off and asking questions what's
your favorite movie
not a bad one I'll check it out
okay your turn
why are you here
good question
why am I here oh I suppose I'm here to
make friends with you
and your dad's
maybe catch some more grasshoppers uh
how'd you get that tiny little scar on
your lips
too personal even for this game my love
was broken when I was born
well I don't have a Scarlet q but if you
could look inside you'd see that my
heart is broken because of what I have
to do today
what do you have to do this is so weird
you're my friend what no matter what
happens I want you to remember that the
others who are coming no more like
people I work with what in the world two
four of us have a very important job to
do it might be the most important job in
the history of the world
this is very unsettling yeah
yeah your dad won't want to let us in
you have to tell them they must
otherwise we're gonna have to find our
own way in do you understand oh my God
the pressure
the cheese is good you have to come
inside right The Strangers
[Applause]
[Laughter]
there were four of them the big one his
name's Leonard he says we had to help
them he says they have the most
important job in the history of the
world this does sound made up yeah yeah
weapon oh it just sounds like the
ramblings of a kid
there's the knock at the cabin
I counted seven knocks that was a very
precise amount of Knocks
that Daddy Andrew or daddy Eric
God I haven't met your delightful
daughter win already
you two should be very proud
[Laughter]
I wish
I'm laughing it's uncomfortable I don't
want to sound rude but we'd like to be
left alone you should know that this
isn't easy for us either the four of us
we never thought we'd be here talking to
you nice people so creepy I love Dave
Bautista me too man speaking to adores
making a difficult conversation near
impossible
oh God that is
I'm calling the police now
I love how immediate this is is this
really kicked off
you're right there's no dial tone I
checked it when we got here is the
battery dead battery's not dead it's not
dialing do you have cellular devices
would you have cell reception out here
though we don't have a choice yeah well
we don't have a choice either we're
calling the cops hey um
we know you can't do that
[Laughter]
sorry we have to cut the phone line
like
the awkward like politeness that they're
approaching this whole situation with is
so odd I'm giving you one last chance to
open the door
that'll stop yeah man
none of this would do anything
that's creepy
oh
to have this fight in a robe let's make
a run to the car
oh my goodness
ouch
[Music]
this is so bizarre
I don't get the impression Ronald
Weasley wants to help yeah I don't oh
whoa oh damn
his action shots he picked up from glass
man it feels like everybody and it is
just in a reluctant situation Andrew
enough
how do you know for sure that's Andrew
French
is this when they first met the parents
assuming so
always together
even during a break-in
I feel like that's gonna hurt later
I've never watched this show before but
I like it
foreign
[Laughter]
we're not here
with hate or Prejudice and our hearts
not at all we don't have one
we had no idea you were a single-sex
couple until we got here well I guess if
you promise then I have to believe you I
mean we're normal people just like you
ah you guys already know my name is
Leonard
I'm from Chicago I'm a second grade
teacher and I run the after school
program I'm also a professional
bodybuilder
I'm Redmond and I like long walks on the
beach I don't like beer
doesn't change what we have to do
or what they have to do when you say
stuff like that you just scare them
my father used to beat the [__] out of
me like Andrew just did
me this thing
may I speak now
I don't think they should have let him
talk I mean why else bother introducing
yourselves to us right if you're trying
to
change us it's a multi-level marketing
company
I'm Adrian
hi before I got up here I I was a line
cook
I love to feed people that's all over
the place yeah I'm like I need to know
what happened here
well Sabrina almost got the vibe that
like maybe her half-sister she was
talking about maybe was being like held
up
do you like cats when you don't have to
answer sweet
sorry win maybe I'll put it back on
later because they seem to be forced
into whatever this is It's Time
they're the Grasshoppers ah yes the four
of us are here to prevent the Apocalypse
what
ultimately whether the world ends or not
it's completely up to you three
you are having a psychological break of
some kind
[Music]
your family must choose to willingly
sacrifice
one of the three of you in order to
prevent the apocalypse oh my God like
what I know is an impossible decision
you must then kill the one you choose oh
my God or if you fail to follow through
with the sacrifice
the world will end I vote when
the rest of humanity
perish
and you will be left to wander them
devastated Planet alone
permanently and cosmically
damn
what was it the cabin itself could have
just been anybody in this cabin
not here to hurt you we wanted to hurt
you we would have used duct tape instead
of rubbish
space from experience I imagine we're
not sacrificing anyone not now not ever
even if I believe the world was at stake
which I don't
waste of time
Never Gonna choose to do this
shut up regimen you just vomit
everything you think
this dialogue is so funny
I've been shown exactly what will happen
if you choose not to make a sacrifice we
couldn't stop drawing the Visions we saw
oh the opening credits was them oh yeah
Sabrina Adrian Redmond divisions two
that led us to each other and
and that led us here the napkin the
child like the school tests the nurses
documents
this is wild actually I mean if they all
had divisions yeah first the cities will
drown it's in a terrible plague will
descend and people will rise with fever
and mucus will fill their lungs this is
psychotic
it's delusional I believe him
going to happen
and we've been shown that only your
sacrifice can stop it somebody who by
what how'd you find each other for every
no you give us we will unleash a plague
for the sins of humanity
Leonard will you make a choice
what happens if they don't make a choice
the Symmetry and these shots is so
fascinating to me
I don't quite understand a lot of the
choices but I'm very intrigued
is he going to unalive himself I think
so
let's go away
oh well if the four of them just do this
then they're scot-free
oh my God he's just gonna slam his head
in there isn't he
[Music]
oh
oh excuse me he's gonna believe the
light and his concussion and then this
this isn't really whoa
oh
nicely done that's not what I thought
was gonna happen I thought I was gonna
slam his face I did too yeah I just got
a daredevil himself
some interesting action shots in here
meanwhile
flashback continued
you can pray if you want I won't make
comment
oh he's a Believer Mr and Mrs Brooks yes
my wife couldn't be here today this is
her brother
and my my her brother will choose
equally
on my wife's behalf
you never should have adopted me
why did it have to be you help me take
Redmond outside
damn
looks like the one from the Mexican
restaurant became the most thick-skinned
of them all yeah
I love the stunt casting they did with
Rupert Grint
like he's famous we don't think he'll
die early
but man like his uh his accent though is
pretty
solid he made an impact for the little
time he was in here mm-hmm
well I'm sorry but I'm gonna have to
change the channel for a little bit okay
go [__] yourself Mr Rogers
please
doesn't get much better than that are
they looking for something just that
would show
a live change
oh my God is this [__] real
oh
Pacific tsunami warning center issued
its strongest warning to the islands of
Hawaii is this what we're supposed to
see
oceans like Fists
please watch
headed south towards I love Dave
Bautista in this he's so good I love his
Evolution as an actor second massive
earthquake has struck in the Pacific
registering 8.6 on the Richter Scale
there it is
area scientists have long feared would
produce a catastrophic earthquake
oh my God and Eric's a believer the
tsunami has indeed hit the Oregon
Shoreline and we have footage shot
minutes ago from Cannon Beach
how'd they get this footage oh it's a
live stream okay
dude this is a nightmare of mine
amazing live stream quality
keep recording
whoa keep recording
do you you have to believe it doesn't
matter if we believe your craziness the
answer is still the same oh no he's
about yeah
I just need a moment
he needs to pray to Jesus
[Applause]
[Music]
officially impressed
okay
when M Night loves to do movies about
faith
does seem to be a common theme
oh come on one second
[Laughter]
look at you
oh
I missed that religious stuff was so
tired and boring from another time and
people were scared of Shadow I believed
them look out onto the boardwalk and I
saw the others we were all wearing the
same colors we saw in our Visions
got it that's what I knew I wasn't alone
so wow they really had this resolve
individually
to come here we're all on the same side
I'm on my family's side
not for long Eric
you gotta sacrifice a non-believer in
the family
Jesus plays soccer
I think uh my money's on the believer
my head's still ringing but my vision is
clearer is that a double meaning
I know nah hmm
them all I want to make sure you're
thinking straight
without the kind of manipulation
they take you alone in there and try and
talk to you I don't believe them
well you should I think they're telling
the truth
go when
God his voice has such a boom to it yeah
oh
okay yeah massively loud lettered
suddenly gets really quiet
we've always been targeted we
Redmond
is the guy from the bar
oh
we all met him for the first time on
that Boardwalk stop the [__] we
don't know why each of us is here it's a
coincidence the man who attacked me and
had me in years of therapy is one of
your groups it's called fate everything
has to be right didn't he tell us about
this cabin on the message board first
then we all had visions of a cabin I
don't know no we have divisions first oh
no we're not done while we're here
go to sleep
this is so Eerie man if you could hear
them laugh you'd understand why I'm here
maybe you'd sleep better you could see
each other easier
it's love how sincere Dave Bautista is
I believe he believes it yeah exactly
ooh
one once you pointed out like the
Symmetry and the shots man I can't stop
seeing it everywhere you're in an echo
chamber you know that right you got
online and you found random people who
had random visions and you took that as
evidence remember the guy who shot up
three people in an army base in
Louisiana
thanks thanks and then we decided to
meet on the boardwalk you're gonna do
that
it's really hard to keep your hand
movement subtle yeah let alone the noise
I'm the next one to go you're like
My Last Hope here Adrian
come walk out of here right now
yeah
nothing will happen
ready
no man as a mother believe me when I
tell you that this is really happening
and it's up to you goddamn
We're not gonna do what you want us to
do
his name is Charlie
Charlie Manson
he likes pancakes
I like pancakes
look
you guys are delusional you're part of a
suitable can't you see that
would be the time to keep cutting man
yeah
you don't have to do this inside the
house do you just gonna have to clean up
the ground
I hope they're like I never liked you
Beth
foreign
I'm over into the other room so they
don't have this here
I'm assuming Dave Batista will be last
yeah
he made sure look Downs in these areas
have already begun as numbers rise along
with fear for the safety of those
infected come on Eric I think
I think person
or a figure in the light behind you when
you were standing behind Redmond when
the concussions was really kicking in
yeah this guy has been checking his
watch all morning just like yesterday
all four of you have watches would you
just shut up here like that no you knew
you were coming out of this particular
cabin where cell reception wouldn't
exist yeah
it's a TV show Leonard
Sabrina all of them knew this X9 show
would be on and at what time Andrew is
very logical they knew this virus show
would be on at this time just like they
knew the Alaskan earthquake and the
tsunami warning had already happened
before they showed up here it does put
very good logic in there
[Music]
now I'm
going to win
[Music]
We're Not Gonna yell anymore okay when
it's five
five four win yes
God damn it ah
everyone needs you no no I don't believe
you no no no no back away God this is
intense
lack of circulation I like how they have
like a playbook
for certain situations yeah
oh
you [__]
Lies We have to help each other
oh yeah I'll take that
it's a strong window
thank you
damn yeah no this this is a suspenseful
ass [__] right here
oh my gosh
stop
[Laughter]
keep going
I don't know this actor but he's I don't
know either man I feel like I've seen
him somewhere he's definitely like I
feel like the highlight of this whole
thing is knee I know
slash the tires damn it oh is he just
gonna drive off
kill Leonard
a letter it's gonna have two assault
rifles in his hands if only he had the
clip at least filled in first
I know you've been through a lot of
people shoot him drop the weapon
and move away from Erica I'll show you I
was chosen to put a bullet in your head
sacrifice completely
what was the plan here yeah I don't know
you have a temper oh now we're in the
show mind Hunter
you set the life out of some situations
I'll accept that straight up looks like
mine hunter
get your drunk ass back to your seat
I wasn't provoking oh
are you okay open your eyes open your
eyes wow no no one fought back on that
guy that guy there's an hkp30 German
engineered very light very easy to
handle I'll take it
that really shaped him didn't it seems
like fate brought him here mm-hmm
no Leonard
are you willing to make a sacrifice
she's already dead
[Music]
oh he's checking the wallet was it him I
don't can't tell by that look
it's okay
[Music]
ah yes you're wrong about all of us
now get in that bathroom later oh no
mistake I will kill you if I have to
Leonard's gonna be the only one walking
the Apocalypse
if you're right
oh God
[Music]
we've now entered Leonard's movie
[Laughter]
go get us
you have a gun
yeah
if I open this door and I see you I will
shoot you
foreign
okay I was like there's no way
he used the glass on himself
oh
no don't don't shh
[Music]
you guys played this so stupid before
you guys played this you'll see that
everything I said was going to happen No
One's Gonna Do what you said find images
as we see yet another passenger aircraft
God damn it Eric
oh my God
they are uh wonderfully intact
[Music]
that's the Eerie image yeah that is
eerie
Everlasting Darkness descend over
Humanity we now have confirmation of as
many as 700 airplanes having crashed
good God
coordinated Cyber attack
airports around the globe are canceling
flights
good
disquieted tragedy
more
oh and what we're seeing now isn't the
fireworks
this is just the final flickering Sparks
nicely put do you really think it's all
just a coincidence I think it's all
coincidence or it has to be a trick
I have to believe that that's what you
believe
I know on someone's life
he teaches second grade
when I'm gone you only have minutes to
stop everything
after that it'll be too late
no no
put your music on until one of us comes
to get you
chicken
I hope Eric kills Andrew and the
apocalypse still happens
and I know when the Visions into the
screaming
it's gonna go on
you know what I love most about teaching
kids they believe everything you say yep
will you make a choice
and save the world
who has the gun
all of humanity has been touched
[Music]
that was instantaneous
they must be using the volume technology
that Disney has in order to project this
would it be if Andrew's the one who she
kills her
that was such a Believer yeah
do it man there was something in the
light
figure
I believe you
wow
sort of the Apocalypse yes
kill me no sweetheart we're running out
of time I won't be scared wow
do it while I'm thinking the most
beautiful thought so that I can have
that feeling in my heart to take me
right to wherever it is I'm going
oh this is sad
yeah this is breaking my heart a little
bit
would you live your life exactly as she
wanted to oh wow you guys are locking up
her office because you guys are going to
dinner
everything we always hoped for
oh
[Music]
wow
all right sweetie let's go
oh she knew
and no one will ever know the hard work
they did
another sad thing too is because they
did it they won't ever know if it was
[__] or not
yeah
there's the truck at least it took care
of some overpopulation problems for a
few hours
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's one way to put a spin on it
oh
my God
foreign
[Music]
the memory lives on of him
Jesus
I mean just for it to be that song man I
just think it's just a rubbing in his
face a little bit too that it was fate
post credits come on have Eric resurrect
the second coming of Eric I don't know
who that guy is Ben Aldridge
who is he he was amazing yeah man I
don't think I've seen anything with him
before
I gotta look it up
because he was I gotta say like out of
the whole thing he I think he was the
standout for me he was the most
surprising to me yeah yeah
I really love Dave Bautista's work a lot
on this though
yeah
there's a lot of Larry like
subtle emotions that were bubbling up
just from his the character itself let
me see if there's a post-credit scene no
there's something at the end
okay I got spoiled for me
do we want to wait for it it's not a
post-credit scene
then what is it I'm just gonna tell you
it totally ruined the moment for
everyone here who made it this far
you hear a knock
knock yeah oh you dick
I know I ruined everything how dare you
but I'd rather get to talking about it
well Michael what did you think my
friend
it was just a tension filled throughout
the entire thing like it has a little
bit
of that kind of tongue-in-cheek M Night
Shyamalan feel to it where the
characters are just a little wacky
enough that it's as fun or at least they
were maybe exaggerated
maybe a little less so than some of his
previous films but the whole concept of
it
in a way
adds to the surrealism of the entire
experience and it's just so yeah
unsettling and there's just some really
good performances throughout and I just
I didn't know what was going on but I
was like thinking about it we were kind
of like waiting to see if there was
anything in the credits or whatever I
was like you know kind of like the whole
like M Night Shyamalan twist thing
that he is it the twist that this one
literally didn't have one it was like
played straight the entire way through I
mean the the twist
if if the The Twist is you know
it's more just like a reveal like it's
just more it's more of a conclusion than
a Twist you know because I I don't know
about you but pretty early on you're
like okay well the apocalypse is
definitely real like very early on it's
pretty obvious the apocalypse is real
like I think the movie could have done a
uh if there's one one thing about it
that I think it could have done a
slightly stronger job at doing is if
because there are there are bits of it
that are
okay I want to clarify I really really
enjoyed this movie before I know like
when you when you like immediately go
into like some criticism about something
it can be offset with oh Greg must not
like it but no that's not the case I
actually really really enjoyed it and I
feel like it actually would have even
had it's got a it's it's well received I
think it would even have a stronger
reception if it was an M9 Shyamalan
because if this was some indie film that
came out
you know and there was like up and
coming director I think it would have
had a much stronger reception
um even though it is well received
overall
when it's at Night Shyamalan I notice
people do have a more critical eye on on
what's right being shown you know and
not to say that anyone's criticisms are
invalid of the film I just think that
people would probably lean a little bit
more towards actually who is this guy
this guy has a lot of potential to make
something you know truly Stellar uh and
it's like I think some things could have
been breathed a little bit better there
were some clunky editing stuff and as
far as the the fun part of the debate is
of is the apocalypse real or not
it it other than like the guy who plays
Eric like his acting was so phenomenal
that it was the only part of it that
would sometimes have me go maybe it's
not but more off but most of the time I
was like oh no the apocalypse is
definitely real because it's definitely
gonna happen at the end of this movie
and uh that's the one part of it that I
would that I wish I was sold a little
bit more on of like I just don't know I
can't tell is it isn't it I I don't know
I was like for me like I wasn't
so sure oh okay oh really I was like I
was like that's good to hear
at the end I was like is this going to
be like a missed situation where they do
finally like
do the deed and then
maybe it happens I don't know I don't
even that's not even a good that's like
the opposite of what this was yeah but
you know what I mean like at least like
they they go through all of this and
then they learn like it was all a scam
or something like that like what if
people threw it and it was like so they
had a he went outside and there was like
a laptop hooked up to the TV or
something and they were playing that
stuff for them to sell this narrative
like that's very committed in my head
there was still like I mean look what
they did man they were offing themselves
for this yeah
this is the most committed scam
but like I don't know I don't know man I
mean I guess you're right about that I
think it would have been something it
was like it was like at times it seemed
like his his explanations of how they
could be faking it seemed
like stretches in and of themselves yeah
exactly so then I was like well what if
what if they did go that extra mile to
make it seem like this stuff was coming
down so I was like I wasn't too sure
yeah where we were gonna land the plane
so to speak in the end yeah yeah this
one's well well done there by the way uh
what I I was I was thinking it would be
hilarious if if if uh you know one of
them did die and then uh the apocalypse
still happened like the best I would
have I kind of thought that was what was
gonna what they were gonna happen it
would have been down with that ending I
I like I would have totally been okay
with that too to be honest because they
were like so on the fence about it and
he did say you literally just have
minutes to figure this out and if they
did just wait too long or maybe if they
just didn't go through with it like what
if they didn't make that decision this
is the movies the movie's a little bit
like funny games meets
some other movie that I'm sure someone
else can be pull and sound smart pulling
it
there's no movement it is there is it is
interesting it's like it's his first
movie where I I did because I like these
like contained home invasion Thrillers
and the Twisted you know the reveal of
that it's not really a home invasion
Thriller like I think there's a lot of
clever qualities to it because when they
do invade it's straight up like oh this
is a home invasion movie and and it is
it kind of just drops you into this
moment in time and instead of like
really building up to it I I I like the
the kind of weird structure it has where
it does just plop you into this
situation but you do see that there is a
an unusual
politeness and consideration to their
behavior you know I do I feel like I
feel like it you know it could have I
think it could have used an extra 20
minutes though to really let some of
this uh
just like breathe a little bit better in
in some of the suspense and little
character moments but there's the other
part of me that I'm like but I actually
completely get the choice to make it a
lot tighter and to just keep it like
constantly moving you know like I
actually so I do see the flip side I
guess there's a alternate movie cut that
I would have I wouldn't have mind seeing
just to because you know someone has
done some movies where they do slow down
and they and you do just get some of
these slower scenes and I I kind of
wouldn't have my mind at that but they
didn't want to keep the ticking talk
around ticking clock around the movie
very much alive and I I think they did
yeah this was this was a fun film and I
don't know sometimes this guy sometimes
it was funny to me so there's a little
bit of a hamminess to it like you were
pointing out like yeah it's just like
the whole situation itself and the way
that these
Invaders quote unquote uh were handling
the situation it just like it it it it's
hard it's just like hard to settle
yourself into like
what is happening here because it's just
they're uncomfortable doing it but they
know they gotta do it it's they know it
sounds crazy what they're saying but
they're still trying to convince you
it's legit like it's like it's
it's just a wacky concept and I you said
this was based on a book
I said it in the credits that I was
based on a book which I imagine I'm
curious to see what that was like what
the what the differences are yeah
yeah I imagine that that book has more
of the things that I was sort of craving
for from the movie probably when I would
when I was kind of at times wanted to a
little bit slow down and just really
deal more in the silence and the tension
and really lock perspective
you know of the carrot of like
of of the characters to see like which
point of view we're really watching this
from because you're kind of what you're
kind of like the audience just sitting
in on it and hopping between
perspectives it's like for the most part
you are adopting the perspective of the
husbands
um for the times I was like I think
we're watching Leonard's movie too
because it kind of feels like it's his
movie as well true but it starts off on
on when so it's like is this through her
perspective and I so I kind of wish it
it would have been cool to see it lock
into a certain perspective or have that
be a little bit more defined whenever it
did switch
um yeah they're like little nuances that
I would have just
would have thought I would have like
really propelled it to me to be like a
nine out of ten or something like that
but but it was very very it was I was
extremely entertained if there's one
thing I don't like it's boring M Night
Shyamalan and they're like oh my God
it's really yeah boring him now it's
really hard to sit through and this was
really important to the last one I saw
which was old I haven't seen old
I won't say anything about it other than
I was extremely bored through images
it's interesting to hear that trailer
was like cool to me oh damn really that
was boring all right interesting I mean
I know it wasn't for some people but I
was just kind of like
yeah
whatever
but like for this I didn't see I didn't
watch the trailer for this oh this is
like you know Rupert Grint wasn't it no
I didn't I I all I knew that was all the
only person I knew that was in this was
Dave Batista because he was on like the
yeah the promos and stuff for it and I
just a little like I saw like the still
and stuff for the trailer and I was like
oh I was like I I just I assumed it was
going to be a home invasion movie with a
Twist
you know out of everything but I just
never watched it out of every actor
every wrestler or he's a wrestler Eminem
he was a wrestler right um out of every
wrestler turned fighter I mean what the
hell much I say wrestler turned actor
I'm also looking at the IMDb for that
other guy but then I was like oh he's in
Hogwarts Legacy then I realized I was on
rubric rents uh I'm gonna get myself
confused here
um yeah out of every wrestler turned
actor I think he's absolutely the best
one uh out of them all you know like
like you know John Cena and Dwayne
Johnson of course uh they have amazing
Charisma and Screen presence as well
uh but Dave Bautista is like a legit
he's he's the most actory of them all
like yeah and he's definitely committed
to it because he
he's developed like this passion for it
and you hear like in his interviews and
stuff and like just kind of seeing like
his Arc from his first acting role to
here like he's improved
drastically and he's really pushing the
craft at least that's why he's like
trying not to get strapped into any
certain type of uh projects and stuff
like that he's like playing around and
I'll say that like
and you you could probably attest to
this a little bit too John Cena kind of
had his stick for a long time and I
think
maybe that was a a grave he dug for
himself yeah but I think we finally saw
some glimmer of what he can potentially
do
with like Peacemaker oh Peacemaker some
of the scenes in that like it's like man
it the some of the moments in that it's
just like man I'd love to see like him
really kind of push these limits a
little bit more somewhere else whereas
Dave Batista's already really started to
explore himself a lot more like that I
think he creates for like I I really
feel the entire history of the character
like in a role like this I I fully
believed everything that I I was like I
actually can see this guy you know under
different circumstances being a second
grade teacher being someone who looks
after kids yeah you can see it in just
the way he talks to them in the way he
responds to their interactions with him
he's very believable and I like the
approach of a home invasion movie where
they they're not just like a bunch of
crazy people being in here to torture
you know it they're they're they're
they're really here finding a good cause
you know there are starting to they're
trying to do something good and I think
his performance had a great balance of
like yeah it's scary in this sense of
like I was never quite there's tension
in the film yet I was never really
scared there are scenes that were
suspenseful
um like I think tension is the most
important element they had to get down
and I did think there was tension and uh
it wasn't a scary film to me but there
were like Eerie moments of suspenseful
stuff but I think the the presence of
Dave Bautista who does not limit himself
by his physique which I think is really
cool uh because while it's acknowledged
in almost every role he does it you see
past it every time because uh uh but
anyway my point being with Dave Bautista
here is that like he he he is like scary
in the conviction that he has and you
know it's he's so fully believes it and
he he brings this sincerity to it and I
think he does that with like every role
he gets and I get why he would want to
like give up a character like Drax where
he is just sort of funny and goofy while
while good in it
um yeah no this this is like a showcase
for the caliber of talent this guy is
and he's even like Glass Onion even that
movie you know he's
he's just he's a solid actor and I'm
excited for more ever since Blade Runner
2049 I was like damn what this guy can
really act I still need to see that oh
as well as the original
I really like the original but whatever
I've seen the ending monologue in a film
class but I've never actually seen the
movie right right that's how that's how
that's how it should go
um
this guy's name is Ben Aldridge the guy
who plays Eric okay so uh he might be
British
I don't know he played Thomas Wayne in
the penny worth show
he was in fleabag as [__] guy
um
yeah I've
I don't think I've ever seen this I
don't think I've seen any of this guy's
work he's been working for quite a few
years
it kind of reminds me of a I feel like a
guy probably came from from theater
I just get that impression of him he is
from the UK okay it's based off though
the things he was his credits on IMDb
working I was like he's probably British
and he is British yeah which would make
and he probably does come from theater
with that in mind
um yeah and I I really feel like
um
his his performance in particular
brought such a such a great intensity
response to so much of the situation and
I I thought you know you see Jonathan
Groff you're like okay it's dropping
Groff's got to be the lead and I was
like oh no it's definitely this guy this
guy he's he's the lead character in this
and he's the one with the full-fledged
uh character Arc and I think it is like
a cool I think it is a cool character
Arc where the circumstances of
everything like it's like when you're
judging what is it um when you when
you're on a jury like proof Beyond A
Reasonable Doubt and like he just gets
to that point and as a character who's a
lawyer uh you're like yeah he needs that
and he gets to that point or be honest
that's a good call yeah he's amazing
what'd you think of when
I think it's time you really heavily
criticize a child actor if it's good or
bad
I thought she was all right
I've seen way worse no that's like child
actors I thought you had a lot of really
great moments so like she was endearing
when she needed to but there was a
couple of moments where it was just like
and that's a kid acting yeah yeah but I
mean overall there were some moments
where I thought she was really I liked
her quieter moments a lot too yes yes I
think her scene at the end in the in the
truck when they're with the radio with
the song because you know that song
obviously has such a memory for them and
a bonding moment yeah and they're both
deciding whether or not they can listen
to it you know I thought that was
amazing is it okay or is this wrong yeah
I'm not sure like what to do
and ah yeah that was a sweet moment uh
Jonathan Groff was
he's good he's on the graph is good in
almost everything he does I thought it
was good
it's 100 yeah like Matrix Revolution
resurrections
yeah have you seen mine hunter
no I have not oh my god
um it's not gonna get picked up again
but uh Jonathan that's that was my
introduction to Jonathan Groff who's the
David Fincher Netflix show and uh yeah
he's he's in he's incredible in that
show that was my introduction to him and
I think he's awesome and of course you
know I've seen him in the Hamilton
Disney plus thing and that was my
introduction to him
yeah you got a much more fun
introduction and then Rupert Grint uh I
think it's kind of smart when actors
like this choose you know when they're
when they because it's like you know you
see Rupert Grant and I think he's still
definitely a lot of people have seen a
lot of his other work of course I still
think for the masses though you will go
look hey it's Ron Weasley you know like
I've honestly I
was a
outside of Harry Potter and all that
like I haven't seen any of his recent
stuff like post all of that I don't
think I have either and the only other
thing I can recall that I saw him in I
can't remember the name of it I think it
was like driving lessons I think he was
something he was doing while like
between Harry Potter films or something
like that which was that was fantastic
he did do a movie called driving lessons
but I think to be in like uh even if you
don't have like a very long Roll But A a
role with a lot of screen time if you
can have a role where you are doing
something very different than what the
masses know you for but it makes still a
very strong impression I think that's
that's great
um because yeah he's done a lot of work
since the Harry Potter stuff but
yeah I personally need to see more
because I'm like I don't even know what
90 of this [__] is that I'm reading
right now never even heard of it uh yeah
everyone was good I thought every
performer here was pretty good and um
they were all
they were all so believable
and I think that's the thing that I was
kind of stricken with the most about
this is I felt like that everybody
fell into their the skin of the
character really nicely and you don't
always have that in a lot of films where
you feel
the dis like a lot of times I not it's
rare I think for a lot of films to have
like every character
feel genuine and not like you're seeing
the performance if that makes sure
true and I think they did a really good
job in this with that
I've seen I've had Shyamalan do some uh
worst dialogue before and so one
thousand percent so the dialogue to me
the times the dialogue's a little like
like very literal very on the nose
um but I don't know it's a bit it's just
like I'm at the point where I can
sometimes just laugh with some of the
dialogue that can be a little goofy and
still enjoy it like laugh in a weird one
maybe this is not what's intended but I
feel like I'm laughing with the movie
and not at the movie right even if I'm
like I'm sure he's aware of some of that
he's Gotta Be by this point at least
yeah I mean he's a
he's that kind of filmmaker and and I
think you know he's he's also that kind
of um
he loves talking about faith like it's
such a through line with I haven't seen
old I don't know if that deals with
faith I think so much of what he
generally does that the oftentimes The
Core theme is about faith and it usually
has a bit more of a uh hopeful angle I
want to say uh but seeing him
go down uh a darker path on the
repercussions and the sacrifices of
faith is is an interesting choice uh to
me and so I I like seeing him branching
off into that because faith has been up
for since the sixth sense it's been such
a
sick like he did like six cents uh
Unbreakable
signs the village and like so much so
much about faith in those films you know
and like belief more you know is is a as
a common common thing and this is again
a bigging I don't even know what if he
has religion or not he strikes me like
he would be Christian or something like
that or at least grew up with it just
because Christianity is often an element
infused in his films
um but it was cool to see that like I
was like the four horsemen reveal I
think it's just like yeah it's just like
a little group it's goofy to me but I
I'm like all right whatever
it's goofy but I'm I'm in I'm in I'm
entertained by it so yeah I was I was
throwing I was thoroughly entertained
and easily engaged throughout like this
was uh same this I never checked out
once through this not not at any point
which
may I can't
I think maybe six not six cents sorry
signs might have been the last time
where I felt like I was on through most
of the movie like that with one of his
oh really
[Music]
I completely forgot about the split I
will take that back I I I I split was I
had that one had me from beginning to
end I just completely forgot that was
even on there uh and then uh I still
need to see glass oh you mentioned split
it's fine no unbreakable is my favorite
of his that's my likewise it's easily my
favorite movie he's ever done and
I I really like split I'm not I don't
love split but I really really like it
and and uh glass I I did not like for
most of it I thought it was really dumb
but um and that that was that was the
most disappointed I've ever been with an
M9 Shyamalan movie because he had like
two great ones and uh but and then uh
what was what is the hell is the name of
that one movie he did with the
grandparents that's the one that
surprised everyone oh that was really
entertaining
yeah
shh I cannot remember what the hell you
know I do have a computer in front of me
where I can look it up I do man you're
just listening stuff off that I
completely forgot about no I mean it's
like he because he had he he's got a
reputation that's a good one too I
didn't but that when I went into that
one I didn't realize there was an M like
movie until after the visit is what it's
called yes that was actually really good
yeah that was really that was really
really entertaining I thought that was a
very entertaining film I vividly
remember watching that movie and wanting
to just
scream at some kids who would not shut
the [__] up yeah
Jesus I had to see it I think we ended
up seeing it twice because it was just
like I couldn't hear anything like these
kids were just talking through the
entire movie I haven't seen the show he
Helm servant I haven't seen that I've I
haven't either I I've heard oh I've
heard decent things about it oh this
makes sense to me now because Rupert
Grint is on servant
he's like uh he's been on 37 episodes it
says here
um so that makes a lot more sense now
how linked up for this film
and why I'd probably do a much smaller
roll okay this makes a lot more sense
now
all right okay oh that's fun to know
that's fun to know but um yeah overall I
thought it was an entertaining film it
doesn't really hit me in a in a shock
way like I feel like the ending's
supposed to really pack a punch and I
don't really it doesn't pack a punch but
the thing is I'm like you know I was
very I was very entertained throughout I
was I didn't it didn't leave me with
like a
like uh
a strong takeaway emotion
um in in that way of I mean like I don't
really like the ending of the Mist
honestly I really like that movie but I
I'm one of those people who doesn't like
that ending
yeah
it's because you just had to wait like
30 seconds I hate that so
so I don't like that anyway but that at
least leaves like an impact of like oh
man what an emotion that it leaves you
with and this one was like yeah okay we
got there I had a this one one of the
conclusions it would have that would
have happened
do you uh if you've ever are you in a
roller coaster guy
uh yeah man I've been on a [__] ton of
roller coasters yeah this felt like you
know you went through the whole like
shebang you've and then you're just kind
of setting at the like the ending of
this movie after all this like crazy
stuff is just like all right and now
we're we're just kind of waiting
waiting to get off the ride now
that's actually not a bad bad four for
that like the the it's it's not the
destination it was the journey yeah
kind of thing yeah yeah I'm right there
with you
I think I think by no means like perfect
or the ending I don't think is like the
big old
yeah but like I I thoroughly had fun
throughout the entire run time though
yeah
um and honestly there's not much more I
can really ask for uh when it comes to a
film like this like it it really
succeeded at that and I think yeah
having some of those flashbacks even
last a little longer would have behoove
the film just just so you those are you
really I mean I'm sure there's those
people out there who are like devastated
by the end you know uh when but with
Jonathan Groff but for me I just wasn't
invested enough I guess I like it was
like on the borderline of like
popping a tear though myself yeah and I
think what I like though uh you know
it's just because we were setting it up
the entire movie I think that's one of
the things I was kind of already
preparing for it very early on for one
of them not to make it out of the cabin
yes I do I do think that
um
one thing I really like about this movie
is the portrayal of
of this um gay relationship and that
they're they just feel like
I know quite a bit of I mean I'm sure
you do too I know quite a bit of gay
people and I have these these neighbors
who I have like two different kinds of
gay neighbors I have like this they're
both all men but there's there's one set
of neighbors who have become very very
close with uh and they are not exactly
like them but they're the ones that
correlate them the most too because
they're very like Macho men they're very
very Macho Man and uh the uh like buff
guys I love to go shooting they're
they're very they're very very very
Macho and it's it's fun seeing that in
here I like seeing this kind of
portrayal where yeah it's part of the
character like especially with one of
them where it does feel very targeted
but the movie's not
about them being gay it was it was just
kind of cool to see a thriller where the
two lead protagonists are gay guys but
they're they're not portrayed like two
stereotypical gay guys in in a movie you
know like one of them in particular
they're they're portrayed just like
human beings as as they ought to be
there's particularly like human beings
and one of them is in particular is a
very tough human being you know which is
something I you really just don't see
that much of and if it is if it is they
kind of make a thing out of it like oh
he's the Gary tough guy yeah I mean I
like that little moment that they had
when they flashed back to the bar before
Rupert Grint interrupted it yeah where
they were calling out their flaws yeah
whatever's like you're quick to throw a
tantrum sometimes or whatever and he was
like yeah and like it's just like a very
like truncated and
like tactile way to just kind of get how
comfortable and healthy their Dynamic
has become so it's not like I don't know
I just felt real
it didn't feel like
tacked on or anything like that it just
there's a nice little moment in the real
world kind of
creeped in in its own weird way but
I I really like the the portrayal of
this relationship and then them adopting
this kid and how they were hoping for
this future
and it was just beautiful man yeah I
really believe their marriage and it
felt very human and
it's something that
I guess I'm I'm so used to it in in real
life that
sometimes I do forget that like oh yeah
this is this is not the norm in a in a
movie you know yeah like you don't
normally you know it's not a normal
thing you see in in movies like to just
have like a
just like a a casual portrayal of it
like I don't even like putting too much
emphasis on it because
I'm not I don't want to make it seem
like I'm crediting myself for like being
like hey I'm so accepting of this it
it's so it is not
as that common that I guess that's more
of the word that I would want to use
it's just not that common and to me in
real life it's common but seen in a film
that it's I'm like oh yeah yeah in in
films this is not common to see that so
I wanna I do want to give credit to that
because it doesn't
it doesn't ever seem to step the movie
never seems to be like hey look at us
look how we're doing this isn't that
cool and I think that's cool how they
they don't make a they don't give a it's
not giving a big Pat on a pat on the
back for themselves it's not like how
Disney handles handles it
you know like Disney whenever they do it
like Disney cut of this movie is just
every every scene of them interacting
just caught up just cut out of the movie
and if they do a slight scene like it if
they do a very very slight gay thing
Disney's always like look how
Progressive we
our first
relationship in Star Wars to the left
side of the screen over there you have
to pause it but you'll see it it's it's
somewhere there other countries won't
see it yeah like they make uh they they
don't it doesn't feel like they're
patting themselves on the back with this
phone right and so and I I think that's
the way it ought to be done to the point
where
people I know for for there is a portion
of audiences that will be like
whoa no because obviously it still
exists
um yeah but I I prefer it in that way
where it is just a normal thing that you
you have to be like oh yeah that's right
this is not common in movies I like
having to check myself to go like oh
yeah that's not common so yeah kudos to
the film for uh its portrayal of that
and the handling baby steps to get into
that point where it's not a topic of
conversation because it's just
a normal relationship that's all it
should be so yeah I like it a lot
um all right guys well what did you
think about not The Devil Wears Prada I
don't know why that movie came to mind
um oh as he did devil
watching knock at the cabinet
would you guys take a knock at the cabin
leave your thoughts down below uh be
sure to follow Michael
uh on Omni media YouTube channel and
I think that's the end of the video
check us on patreon and we will see you
guys soon peace out rude recognition say
Bye Michael
bye
foreign
[Music]